[Music]
okay so now it's 13 to 17 again the end
is slightly different from the MacArthur
to give a finish to this section starts
to get a little bit more involved at
this point okay so really the last
sections of this section just like from
9 is already Australia he sees my
movements 10 stops he parries 11 and
then we both pulled back into 12 and
this is basically the starting point of
the next sequence so both in ski no
kamae he opens up my thrust for 30
parrots he thrusts high block 14 it's 16
double time he sees I'm open comes from
a strike 17 Texan II making sure he
hands you clear here there's some
variation around this and four five six
but we're not showing them in this
sequence before you do another video he
legs on the way that they just keep it
clean
[Music]